les règles les menstrues non rien que le
mot dégueu bah non en fait non c'est à
dire c'est quoi les règles en fait tous
les mois en gros le corps il se prépare
au cas où il y aurait une fécondation
oui donc il se passe plein de trucs et
par exemple la paroi de l'utérus elle
s'épaissit parce qu'a priori c'est par
là que ça va se passer le corps prépare
la chambre d'amis si vous voulez mais
s'il y a pas de fécondation hop on range
on nettoie tout jusqu'à la prochaine
fois et la parole de l'utérus elle
redevient normal et en faisant ça
décolle la muqueuse qui tapisse tout ça
du coup ça saigne un peu et ça coule par
la seule sortie disponible mais c'est
juste du sang normal avec les trucs
qu'il y a parlé d'habitude un peu de
muqueuses les bactéries de la flore
vaginale etc les trucs qui sont là tout
le temps et qui dérangent personne en
temps normal en tout cas qui empêche
personne de venir faire un tour dans le
coin d'habitude d'ailleurs non seulement
les règles c'est pas ça mais les
rapports sexuels pendant les règles
c'est pas dangereux là encore c'est
pareil ça change rien à d'habitude on
n'est pas obligé si on n'a pas envie
mais c'est pas dangereux juste se
protéger de la même façon ni plus ni
moins